hey what is up everybody it's animak
here
for anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the latest events
in black clover and let me tell you we
just got a bunch of
crazy reveals that i think are going to
end up being massively important for the
rest of the story
i was not expecting so many crazy twists
in such a short period of time so we
need to talk about it all
right now if you enjoy the blacklord
content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going please leave that like to let
me know it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or you
just haven't subscribed yet
make sure that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications if you don't do that
you're still gonna miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
finally of course this video will
contain black lower manga spoilers we
are talking about the latest events in
the manga
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned as you will recall at the
very end of the previous chapter
the focus switched away from knocked and
the plan to infiltrate the spade kingdom
and we got a glimpse of noel waking up
in a strange place
with the surviving elves standing over
her
up to that point we didn't know what
happened to noel memo sassacre
and the other characters who had been
inside the heart kingdom when vanica
attacked
now it was pretty obvious to all of us
who know black clover that all of these
important characters will survive
despite the powerful explosions that
they were subjected to
tabitha is not the type of author to
kill off a bunch of important characters
off-screen so of course in the latest
installment of the story we learned that
everyone is pretty shaken up
but very much alive and this includes
along with noel
mimosa sacred charmy luck and leo
and along with the elves all of these
characters are now
located in a secret and mythical realm
known as elysia which is an unexplored
land
inside a grand magic zone within the
heart
kingdom this place is just overflowing
with thick
and extremely powerful mana and the
surviving elves have been residing here
ever since the previous saga of the
story ended
and not only that but as he is
explaining the situation to the black
clover mages pawtry casually drops
a pretty massive reveal along with
poetry raya
vetto and the elf fauna two elf
children are also residing here in
elysia
and it turns out that these children a
boy and a girl
are the descendants of tethya and lyrt
now you may be asking yourself how is
that
even possible didn't tethya die during
the elf massacre
and wasn't her child killed with her 500
years later this same child was
reincarnated within yuno
so then how could tethya and licht still
have descendants
well as we learn in this chapter despite
being gravely injured
tethya survived the massacre furthermore
it is revealed that tethya had actually
been pregnant
with twins and after the massacre
one of those twins actually survived
sacred then has a flashback in which she
recalls that back when she found tethya
after the massacre tethya was indeed
still alive and so was one of the twins
inside her womb
secret then used her sealing magic to
close up all of tethya's wounds
but by the time that sacred woke up as
the bird narrow
many years had gone by and secretary had
no idea what happened to tethya
or her second baby all of this is a
massive revelation
the fact that direct descendants of
tethya and licht are still alive
in the present could be a huge
development
these children may have insane magical
talents
and potential and they could end up
playing an important role
in the black clover story at some point
in the future
this reveal will also inevitably lead to
speculation
about whether there are even more secret
descendants out there somewhere
and i'm sure that many will wonder
whether asta might somehow be connected
to the descendants of licht
and tethya since we know that asta's
origins and the identity of his parents
remains a huge mystery the idea that
aston
might be related to licht and tethya
isn't
impossible but if he were a direct
descendant of tethya and licht
asta would presumably have massive
amounts of mana
so there would need to be some
explanation as to why
asta ended up being born without magic
i can also see people asking themselves
whether tethya
might actually be osta's mother and this
is because
in the brief glimpse that we got of a
woman that might be asta's mother back
in chapter 242
that woman had a bleeding wound on her
chest just like
tethya after the massacre but even if we
disregard that 500 year time discrepancy
it is clear that the woman in chapter
242 is wearing completely different
clothing from
tethya the caller in particular gives it
away
so no i don't think that asta is
tethya's second twin child
and i definitely wouldn't make such a
vast jump in logic
until we got a lot more evidence but the
idea that asta may
somehow be related to the descendants of
licht and tetia
isn't out of the realm of possibility
but
the reveal about tethyah her second
child and her descendants is not the
only crazy reveal
in this chapter when mimosa asks patri
why the elves decided to save all of
them from the explosions
poetry explains that actually they were
all able to survive and contain the
explosions using their own magic
but in the aftermath of the explosions
they were all severely injured and that
is when the elves arrived apparently
the guardian of this secret realm called
elysia
a deity by the name of dryad sent a
divine revelation to the elves
telling them to rescue the clover
kingdom mages and bring them here
i'll talk more about dryad later on in
the video because that could be
huge as well but first let's get through
the rest of the chapter
poetry is impressed by how much stronger
noel and the others had become in
only 6 months and he is surprised by
their ability to survive a battle with
an
overpowered opponent while also
protecting the civilians
of the heart kingdom however despite
these truly impressive feats in the face
of an
op enemy like vanica noel is not happy
she believes that all of her efforts to
get stronger were pointless
because in the end she still lost to
vanica and vanika was able to capture
and kidnap
loro pechika noel is furious at the fact
that she wasn't strong enough to protect
loro pachika
and she is also very concerned about
poor beaver girl because who knows what
vanica might
do to her i mean sure vernica claims
that she will keep laura pachika alive
until noel gets stronger and challenges
her again
but vanica is a psycho and she could
decide to change her mind
anytime because of this noel begs the
elves to teach her how to become
stronger since they
are stronger than she is at this point
noel basically
loses it she grabs pawtry and shakes him
by the collar while screaming that she
needs to get stronger
right now this definitely isn't how noel
would behave
under normal circumstances i mean she
might act this way with asta
but certainly not with someone like
pawtry clearly tabitha wants us to know
that noel
is under a lot of emotional and
psychological pressure
and so despite being a noble she no
longer cares about manners and proper
etiquette she is much more important
things to worry about
at this point in time pottery asks noel
whether she seriously thinks that she
can get that much stronger
in such a short period of time because
as we know vanica's power is still in a
different league
when compared to noel but noel says that
even though she knows that it's crazy to
think that she could get so strong
so quickly she believes that giving up
would be
even harder than actually achieving her
goal
no matter how impossible that goal might
seem
mimosa secret luck charmy and leo all
agree
and they jump to their feet ready to
train and get
stronger this was a pretty wholesome and
epic moment i have to say
and pachi is impressed when he sees
their resolve
and determination at this time pachi
makes yet
another huge reveal the elves possess
a secret esoteric art called ultimate
magic and poetry implies that he can
teach
this technique to noel and the others
and that is how this short but
information-filled
chapter ends within a very short period
of time
we learned that the elves are living in
a secret magical realm
inside a grand magical zone we learned
that tethya didn't die
during the elf massacre and that she was
pregnant with twins
one of whom actually survived we also
learned that some sort of guardian deity
called
dryad had specifically instructed the
elves to save the clover kingdom mages
and finally we learned that the elves
possess a secret
overpowered magical technique that noel
and the others
are about to learn wow that is a lot
to process obviously i'm extremely
interested in finding out more about
this
ultimate magic that the elves possess
and it seems like noel and the others
who are currently in elysia
are about to experience another major
power-up thanks to
poetry and the elves what's more this
so-called
ultimate magic could end up being a
powerful secret weapon
in the battle against the dark triad
don't forget that the elves
are in many ways the polar opposite of
the devils or
demons the tree of sephiroth is the
polar opposite of the tree of cliphoth
and so the apostles of sephirah are the
polar opposite of the dark triad
so it wouldn't be too much of a stretch
to imagine that
some form of ancient magic that the
elves possess
could turn out to be super effective
against the dark triad
and demons in particular and that brings
me back to
triad that mysterious guardian deity
that told the elves to rescue the clover
mages
and bring them to elysia in greek
mythology
a dryad is a mythical tree spirit or a
tree nymph
so we can assume that the name of this
deity comes from greek mythology
the connection to trees and nature is
definitely there
and elven culture in general right down
to their architecture and fashion
is clearly inspired by ancient greek and
roman cultures in our own world
but beyond just the inspiration i think
triad is perhaps the biggest reveal in
this entire chapter
the fact that intelligent supernatural
deities exist
and that they can actively communicate
with the elves
is a really big deal i have heard a lot
of speculation within the black clover
fan community
about the existence of angels and angel
magic
in this world as the theory goes since
black clover has
devils it might also have angels and
these angels
and their magic may turn out to be
essential for ultimately defeating the
devils
the introduction of dryad might bring us
as close as possible to this idea of
angels
in black clover we don't know much about
dryad
yet but it appears that this deity is
supernatural
and connected to nature and light which
is the polar opposite of the devils
who are connected with darkness and the
underworld
could dryad be just the first of several
guardian deities and could these deities
have the ability
to actually possess humans or elves just
like the devils can
is it possible that a human who is
possessed by a deity like triad
will be able to unlock incredible
angelic powers
powers that will allow them to defeat
the darkness
of the devils those are just some of the
most interesting questions that jumped
out at me
as i read this chapter depending on what
we learned about dryad
in the coming chapters we may be looking
at a brand new species
or race of creatures in black clover
and this new species could be the most
powerful one
yet can you imagine a final showdown
between lucifer
and some sort of overpowered angelic
creature
with divine abilities that would be a
showdown
of biblical proportions definitely let
me know what you guys think how do you
feel about the revelations surrounding
tethya
and her second child and what role do
you think that hers
and licht's descendants are going to
play in the story
also what is that ultimate elf
magic that poetry talked about and what
kind of magic do you think
it will create finally how do you feel
about dryad
and the idea that a whole other race of
angelic
divine beings exists in black clover
perhaps a race of heavenly creatures who
are the very opposite of
devils let me know down below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black lover content
don't forget to leave a like to let me
know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar or maybe you just haven't
subscribed
make this the video do you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications if you don't go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all
you're still gonna miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works feel free to
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i wanna give a big thank you to all of
our anime opera
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
a very special thank you to alpha sigma
and liam thompson
disciples of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons
including ingrata the world a quiet
respect
potefa jonathan king rathune de ora
emperor otaku thomas jones kin mono
admirath and chris torley finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan kings eldris anatoly
kazotsky
angel cruz cricket xp joe stanton very
gucci
alicia octor hinokamian water bonnie
parks
jason wilson florian joanne garcia
steelers
mcshamus jessica kayla fond deadly saint
and stern hawkins if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you